chad wolf is the former acting dhs
secretary joins us right now
uh chad the governor is apparently going
to outline how he is going to utilize
some of those troops from all over the
country that governors are sending
down to the border uh but we still
haven't gotten word out of the bite
administration whether what he's doing
is legal
they've been very quiet on it but i
suspect they're not
for what he's doing since so much of the
land
is federal land where do you think this
is going
yeah neil i think that's right i think
what obviously what governor avid is
doing here is he's protecting
communities in the state of texas and
making sure that
uh there is proper physical
infrastructure to keep
those illegal border crossers out of the
state of texas now
what the biden administration has to do
and dhs needs to do
is to work with the governor instead of
being an adversary to him i think once
the federal government
and governors such as the state of texas
state of arizona work together
they can help solve this problem but if
the federal government chooses not to
enforce
border security laws and they're not
going to build that physical
infrastructure that border patrol needs
then
governors are going to be forced to do
this on their own
you know um chad you and i talked about
this before i really tried very hard to
keep the politics out of the left or
right
but you hear from the byte
administration that um this is being
sensationalized that things aren't
nearly as dire
as the media reports namely fox you know
reported
because we seem to be the only ones
actually reporting what's going on there
uh but i see the numbers every day i get
the stats as you do
from all these border patrol and other
officials uh
and they are what they are they're
records now they're down from the pace
we're at a few weeks ago but not by much
and year over year uh up significantly
close to 45
so uh that being the case
can the administration be taken
seriously if it says it's going to look
at a serious solution
if it doesn't even see the problem yeah
no i think
the administration's got a serious
credibility problem when they talk about
the border
and their efforts along there we see the
numbers at historic crisis and even
though that may not be in the news
every single day and we know other
networks are not covering it
they are breaking the system at that
border there's not enough infrastructure
there's not enough facilities there's
not enough people
to process the number of individuals
that are coming across that border
illegally
every single day and every single month
and the numbers in june
will be even higher than the numbers in
may i'm told so
you continue to see historic numbers and
again this is not just about migrants
coming across the border this is about
cartels these are about smugglers and
traffickers
and the criminal activity that comes
along with that and so we need to get
serious
it's a real issue it's a real issue for
the communities along that border but
it's a real issue for all
american cities that are seeing illegal
narcotics and these migrants
spread throughout the country so we need
to get serious about this issue
and this is uh this is a national
security issue border security is
national security
and i can't emphasize that enough that
this administration is not taking this
seriously enough the security of the
american people seriously enough
and they need to continue to put
americans first as they look at policies
to solve this problem
all right um thank you very much for
that chad wolfe as you were speaking we
were showing some of these outdoor
tensor facilities that have been
constructed to deal
with the wave after wave of migrants and
migrant miners
who flooded the border those aren't made
up images those are real images those
are real numbers and that is a real
crisis
no matter your politics or party
affiliation chad thank you very very
much